thank you
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys and we're
very careful boys and today we're joined
by a careful girl hey what up guys
welcome back of course we love cat
what's up cat hey Cat what's up Cat
hello so you you got into Sheba I got
into you
I did tell us about your experience with
Shiba coin um well I first found out
about Sheba from my boyfriend because at
the time he was scrolling on I forgot
which app it was he was growing he's
like oh look there's another like Shiba
Inu coin there's Dogecoin and there's
this maybe I'll buy some as a joke and
see if it goes anyway so he buys a bunch
like a good amount when it's basically
worth nothing and I end up buying like
maybe like a few hundred dollars worth
uh shortly after him
what ends up happening is he sees that
nothing's happening with the Sheila coin
and he sees nfts are popping off so he
starts buying nfts and he's thinking to
himself you know what if I have to
sacrifice one of my coins I might as
well sacrifice the Sheba coin it's not
doing anything so on October 1st he then
takes all of his Sheba coins and sells
it so he could buy a Yakuza cat who's
like the cat that's pretty cool though
that is Ty it is yes uh it is only dog
coins do well on on yeah and I believe
it was what like October 2nd October 3rd
Sheba in you coin basically [ __ ]
skyrocketed and he loses it out on
basically three hundred thousand dollars
I need to link my boyfriend up with you
guys because he buys all the coins like
when he should but then he sells it to
you bring him over I don't buy [ __ ] like
this though but you know I'm jealous
you're jealous like anybody else oh sure
I mean I've done very well doesn't
matter but but this would have been a
crazy [ __ ] ride that's a guess right
yeah I think that's what I do all the
time though I sell it before boot boost
right before it goes yeah and then I'm
like well I make profit but not like
that kind of profit well my boyfriend
has been punching bag I watched
something boost and then I buy it and
then I watch it
but that's not true anymore my friend uh
so we were talking off camera about the
metaverse yes and how all this stuff is
is kind of launching like nfts related
to different like universes that are
going to exist on the blockchain wow
that you can interact with uh what are
your thoughts on the metaverse uh I
don't really know what it is I saw the
trailer that Mark Zuckerberg had
released of himself in it doing a
conference call one I don't I don't
think he knows how to be a normal person
he looks like a robot yeah he's like a
programmed robot who was given lines so
that was a little weird but what what is
the metaverse is it just like the Sims
uh why do you want to buy stuff for it
have you ever heard of that Second Life
game yeah back in the day yeah it's kind
of like that right where it creates a
whole like Universe like The Sims yeah
like The Sims yeah slash Ready Player
one yeah it's like Avatar oh I see
Avatar yeah on Pandora
but there's a lot of [ __ ] to it like you
could like work out you could do all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] like everyday life
stuff and then like the glasses that
they're developing you can exist in the
real world while in simultaneously in
the virtual so it's like ARB that's the
new things like putting on like an
Oculus and like going into a totally
different digital space but it's like
adapting like your real world
surroundings and then having things work
in that space as well yeah like you're
playing tennis and [ __ ] or whatever and
then your friend is like in Tokyo and
you're playing tennis great example of
this too is me and Anthony are getting
air dropped this this these boots that
are just [ __ ] boots and you can see
them you can see them through AR so you
like look down at your boots and then
you can see your friends boots
potentially if they're in the same room
as you where do I get the glasses from
how do I get the glass Google right now
the tech will be through like uh your
phone for like all the AR stuff but
they're they're developing they've
already worked on things I think there
was like a Ray-Ban iteration that came
out that already is able to like I think
the hard part is taking all that
hardware and putting it into something
so small compact uh yeah so right now
it's like you can take photos you can
kind of like record stuff with glasses
you can start doing a little bit of that
that stuff with the tech but to get it
to where they want to they're they're
literally saying like it's going to take
about five to ten years of development
damn that's for sure the direction that
makes the most sense watch that I mean
imagine you go from Facebook one of the
largest like social marketing social
media marketing connective apps in the
world that has like over a billion
people when they say that they're gonna
invest in a direction like meta and
change their whole name and develop that
out for the next few years it's like
it's gonna work imagine games launching
on The Meta version it's gonna be sick
right where they use these things called
utxos like um to basically transfer
property to between different
blockchains but you don't even really
know that that's happening so say you're
playing like a Spider-Man game and in
that game you get these special boots or
some [ __ ] or special like web Slinger
you can transfer them into a different
game that's also on the metaverse that
launched on the metaverse and you're
wearing your Spider-Man gloves or
whatever the [ __ ] in that game and it's
your unique nft so it's yours and you
could trade it sell it whatever you want
to do Facebook announced that or uh Mark
Zuckerberg announced that GTA is going
to be in the [ __ ] motorcycle imagine
that [ __ ] you're gonna [ __ ] do crime
dude we're gonna rob a liquor store dude
bro can you imagine that's so cool like
you're gonna actually be able to [ __ ]
go up and put that and point out at
people and [ __ ] shoot them
that's exactly you can walk up to cars
and pull it up and [ __ ] go and beat
the [ __ ] out of a grandma in the car you
[ __ ] take it away and drive it no
yeah not hurting anybody not anybody
real yeah yeah just taking away their
time it's like Westworld oh yeah that's
a good one wow that's gonna be so crazy
you know what's crazy I played GTA for
48 hours one day and then when I went to
go yes two days I felt like one though
right right it felt like one day because
I didn't sleep and then I went to go get
some 7-Eleven pizza and [ __ ] because I
got hungry and then when I was driving
through the streets I wanted to [ __ ]
knock over the uh the light posts while
I was driving and I was like man GTA
Central to the store and I was like I
wanted to punch the [ __ ] cash
register dude but I didn't do any of
that [ __ ] because I'm like this is
reality dude I hate when I'm robbing
them and then he pulls out a shotgun
instantly I'm like yo [ __ ] [ __ ] chill
chill [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I was
gonna kill you yeah I hate when I'm
robbing them when you defend themselves
I I do hate that because you don't know
when he's gonna do it and I'm always
like uh now I just killed him instantly
the game they only have [ __ ] 20 in
the register anyway it sucks dude it's
not enough that they're all aware of the
Amendments insurance
it's completely lost dude I think um
when I think of like the movie Inception
remember when uh they go into that scene
with like underground and everybody's
got like that [ __ ] uh drug that like
keeps them hell asleep under so they can
go to like deeper Dimensions yeah and
then like old dark guys just kind of
like [ __ ] like they come here to to
wake up or whatever the [ __ ] he says you
know what I mean where it's like what's
the difference between being in the
dream world versus not I get [ __ ]
stoked about that [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] like I'm down to like no longer
exist in this Dimension and just be
plugged in for the rest of the metaverse
existence Matrix style yeah well you
don't need much right because if you're
if you're in that world and you could
make it look like a [ __ ] Penthouse in
New York City but you're like in the
shitty dinky room yeah what do you care
yeah it's like you can move to like uh
[ __ ] in the middle of America get
giant ass land you know what I mean and
then just [ __ ] you don't even need
Furniture you just need soft [ __ ]
everywhere just in case you don't run
into stuff definitely right yeah dude I
hope by then they have that have you
seen the tech where they the guys
treadmill that goes 360. those are sick
is this the future of retirement homes
are we gonna put like all of our parents
in this it'd be way less depressing than
the retirement homes that exist now yeah
less abuse maybe they're gonna make it
so you can interact with your house so
then you can get like a blank ass house
and then some like boring furniture and
it'll be super cheap but then you could
change the color and all that stuff with
your [ __ ] glass ashes
or you could also like retirement homes
like imagine like they can't they're old
they can't do a lot of physical stuff
right chilling in a wheelchair all day
and you [ __ ] throw like a metaverse
gear on them or whatever the [ __ ]
suddenly they're like flying or running
you know I mean just being able to feel
like you can just be young again I feel
like that's a that's a future I mean
sure AI death and all this crazy stuff
where they take over maybe but I just
think that that's a Direction that's
worth going for yeah it seems inevitable
because at least now we'll have a
generation of old people that actually
played games when they were young oh so
it'll be like more like oh this is what
I want because I used to always look at
old people back and they'd be like y'all
can be playing video games all day I
want you to play some Final Fantasy
sauce having a hurt back but like I
always imagine when I'm old then I can
finally replay every single game
probably in way better HD than it was in
the 80s yeah and that's so true I'll
play all the metal gear solids again and
be so so confused by a storyline but
[Laughter]
really fun
of that
that reminds you of that time yeah yeah
your neurons are like your mind thinks
you're in that time again because it
doesn't know like you know just dates
and anything it's just like observing
and the feelings right because they got
a bunch of dudes that have Alzheimer's
these like geezers right and then they
put them in a dormitory
they dressed up the [ __ ] thing like
it was a college thing right like like a
[ __ ] college dorm and then the guys
would party [ __ ] live like a college
like life dude and then they said their
health memory everything went back up
today's video is brought to you by
curology all right guys shout out to
curology because I've been working with
them now for a little over two years in
my skin routine life I feel much much
better about this process it looks very
clear thank you very much
um if it wasn't for my homeless ways I
think that I definitely would be much
much dirtier here because if curology
never came around I don't think I'd
really washed my face with soap use
vegetable oil uh
I used water to rinse it or I let the
shampoo drip into my face and I just
used that yeah and that's no way to be
an adult that's not skin care it's not
skin care but I was always intimidated
by it so when they first approached me I
was like well first off I'm not a I'm
not a beauty vlogger okay but they're
like no no no check this out okay we're
gonna make this process easy for you you
go online there's a quick little survey
of what your skin goals are like maybe
you just don't want to be an aging old
man maybe you got pimples maybe you got
dry skin or you're oily there's
different type of goals that people have
right because we all have different
needs for skin care and then after you
fill out the survey they create a
specific formula just for me
customized right and I was like dude
that already sounds super Next Level
because one problem I had and why I
avoided skin care is because you walk
down the aisle and there's so many
options that it's overwhelming and I'm
like what am I gonna do with this stuff
I don't know it just says like body wash
for men and it smells and I'm like I
don't know there's too much to read too
much I'd just rather rinse with water
what's wrong with that still get a
girlfriend and then
what I realized is that when the process
was easy it made me want to do it more
right and so I started getting the
curology kit right what it comes with is
a face wash so I could get that down
number two they got face cream my
formula right that by the way it's not
just some robot doing it in this
Dermatology expert knows what the hell
they're doing okay so you got somebody
behind the scenes who you upload your
pictures and then they see what you know
your skin is now and they kind of help
you create this formula and on top of
that this kit too it has a moisturizer
so after you put your cream on you
moisturize it and you keep it nice and
healthy yeah because you don't want to
get your skin products from a expert at
the supermarket no who just bagged the
cabbage and I'm just gonna tell you how
to wash your face right that's why
Dermatology is so important and so if
you're looking for Ultra easy skincare
that's made specifically for you check
out neurology because it doesn't even
matter what your goals are it could be
acne or getting rid of acne dark skin
spots clogged pores fine lines all of
that they take care of all of that and
like Joe said they'll give you a custom
prescription created by a Dermatology
provider made just for you and you take
a short quiz online and they send it to
you every single month so you don't have
to go to any store that's cool and not
just skin care and stuff look they just
came out with this it's it's lip balm I
like the packaging look like bam look at
this you know any company that takes
care of their packaging and makes the
whole experience like ah this is nice
it's going on my body this is going on
my luscious lips baby they got four new
flavors original mint vanilla vanilla
passion fruit
oh they're trying to make me go to
Hawaii yep okay whoa look at this oh
that's a sick one what the hell happened
what the heck's vanilla
oh it's like a lightsaber bro look at
that oh
thank you for sending it I need
something like this because my current
chapstick
it's the kind with the cap sometimes I
pull the cap off and the whole thing
comes out so I actually really like this
especially since I live in hot ass Vegas
where my Chopsticks melting all the time
it smells really good that's cool so get
curology like I did go to curology.com
off the Record to get a free 30-day
trial all you have to do is pay five
bucks for the shipping and in 30 days
you can see a tremendous difference so I
highly recommend giving it a try because
it's free anyways go to curology.com off
the record for free 30-day trial all you
have to do is pay for shipping bro smell
this
oh that was a good one dude just look at
this
look at this the whole before it
'd be like thing right yeah so if we get
[ __ ] Pizza Hut and video games when
we're seniors we're gonna feel like
we're 12 again and just like an older
Asian person kind of just hitting us
[Laughter]
I'm working [ __ ] smacking us dude
right when it's a good part of the game
they just unplug it oh my emotions are
back imagine imagine we have a business
we have a bunch of old people plugged
into VR glasses with Pizzas around and
people are like what are you guys doing
we're like we're treating Alzheimer's
working this is a prescription Virtual
Boy
what I can't wait for is when people are
in like they're in the metaverse now
there are four white walls around them
or whatever right very boring and then
it costs the same as real life to
upgrade their lives that would happen
we're back to zero but that's probably
gonna you think that's gonna that's that
of course is gonna be like that only
early adopters maybe get cheaper if I do
the metaverse early and if I want to buy
I you said I could buy a penthouse in
this metaverse well you gotta buy you
got it yeah it's kind of pricey though
on location too so like it's gonna be
more expensive if it's metaverse in New
York versus like metaverse in Minnesota
so check this oh yeah there's a project
called sand right now and it has the
same kind of thing where the real estate
is based on the congestion of the roads
and where everything's going so you can
you know get Prime real estate in like
more of a city center and that's going
to cost you more money because more
people are going to see stuff you can
also advertise there for like whatever
your business is in game so when you
have your glasses on you can see [ __ ]
yeah dude that is crazy and Snoop Dogg's
actually associated with that but he's
associated with everything yeah yeah
Snoop Dogg's doing a bunch of [ __ ] for
no reason
I think he's doing it for a little bit
of scratch he has a verse on a
Vietnamese song I
don't know who the Vietnamese singer is
it looks crazy like a random verse in a
fully Vietnamese song This Guy's singing
Vietnamese then suddenly Snoop Dogg
comes in starts rapping in English and
then he dips does he have any like
Vietnamese related bars in there I don't
know I don't remember a little bit don't
know why I'm on this track
he's because I'm black because
these references that'd be pretty cool
hey check hella fat hey it's like hell
of fat that'd be cool if he was confused
on the track
the whole verse yeah the whole verse
showed a compilation of all the random
[ __ ] that he was in like he's been in
video games like he's also been in
Bollywood films and music videos like
detergent commercials he's been in like
Ukrainian like soap stuff like wasn't he
in GTA San Andreas as well I think so
that's something I'd want to be in no
[ __ ] yeah
he should be in like sexual harassment
like workplace videos that'd be tight
him tell me like no means no yeah yeah
but like he just like in a cameo in a
situation because then the people at
work would be like oh [ __ ] this is
actually way cooler if you [ __ ] up I'll
kill you you guys hear that yeah
sexually harassed now because Snoop Dogg
remember those old videos back in the
day where all these celebrities were in
situations where someone would say oh
that's gay and then the slogan was like
before you say that's gay are you
thinking about what you're actually
saying like oh [ __ ] they had a PSA Snoop
Dogg would be doing
like HR videos like that he should no
means no time's up me too just in the
metaverse now like that in the metaverse
I feel like snoop's word has a lot of
weight so if he tells you to do
something I feel like a lot of people be
like yeah I'll think about that that's
pretty sure but he's probably also super
high so it's like
sure we got glasses on so you can't
really tell no but you know I think it's
assumed it's a smoke everywhere you know
they think about like this speaking of
Snoop I remember one of Grace concert
moments of my life I mentioned this
before was going to coach Coachella to
watch uh Snoop and Dre and then Snoop
comes out and he tells everybody pulled
their [ __ ] blunts in the air
everybody's smoking hella weed and then
they bring back Tupac as a whole uh that
was crazy oh you were there yeah I was
there I was there and this girl next to
me is like oh my God Tupac's alive and I
was dying I was lit as [ __ ] just being
like this this is brilliant like you can
shoot so high right she was super high
yeah she was super high people were
[ __ ] screaming but I was screaming
too but it wasn't like he's alive it was
just so you're like I'm so entertained
imagine imagine yourself but I knew he
wasn't alive yeah and then you just see
a hologram yeah I don't believe it what
can what can you do in the digital space
now like you're putting a hologram in
the real space we're not even talking
about VR and glasses two two pucks right
exactly three Pockets
um but I guess the idea is like you can
probably have dead people
totally exist in the metaverse not dead
like we probably go to like a Beatles
Concert we could probably go to like an
MJ concert or something like that based
on AI you know how like they make AI
generated songs based on what artists
have done in the past if there's like a
new Beatles album yeah Whoa saying the
things they would have said when you
interview them they have they will do it
do they they said that like we're gonna
be able to go to the era like when we're
studying like history
are you kidding me we'll learn more than
ever because if learning was not engaged
bro I wouldn't be on JK news right now
[ __ ] kidding me
I know right I'd be a [ __ ] a Civic
engineer where would you go first it's
like some magic [ __ ] school bus kind
of [ __ ] where they take you to that area
in that right into the belly and yeah in
that in that meta video because because
you watch the trailer of Mark Zucker but
there's actually a whole over an hour
long video that's really really
entertaining if you play back at like
1.5 x speed
um but like yeah but like you watch the
whole thing they go into like all the
directions and one of those with the
with the education and learning it's
like literally like you put on the
[ __ ] glasses and suddenly you're in
like Roman historical squares and you're
buying [ __ ] fruit they're talking
about and you're hungrier than [ __ ]
so it's gonna be sick as [ __ ] you see
somebody with polio dying and [ __ ]
throwing the [ __ ] tell about the window
oh yeah dude there's [ __ ] tubs you step
in horse [ __ ] you look at the bottom of
your shoe it's there
they don't let you go in the brothel
that's all
restricted that's on spare is like guys
we've been doing this
they're picketing outside in the
metaverse jobs just digital avatars of
themselves
protesting it I like how that that's
what they see that's what they see it
comes Santa Fe damn
you know why those they never look their
part though is because everyone's like
dressed apart but nobody takes care of
their bodies and everybody takes Square
for payment at the freaking when you buy
the rules survive dude from the boobs
it's like 21st century bodies and then
like maybe the close matches but
everyone else it doesn't look right
because you guys have been have you've
been to the Renaissance Fair when when
uh you're wearing a watch or you have
your phone out does that ever happened
to you oh yeah like they'll just like go
watch this device
what is this curious thing you brought
in and I like to make a big deal and
then they just go we accept PayPal so
by the end of it it's like okay well
this is [ __ ] after you've sold me
and I want to buy now we're back to the
future nuggets
we should trade in silver coins or
something so it's nice to know you can
go with the metaverse see that [ __ ] and
that doesn't happen because it's highly
redundant in every stall you go They're
gonna start accepting Bitcoin soon too I
heard a Renaissance Fair nice paying a
Bitcoin would you guys ever get into
like these what do you call it those
role-playing worlds like yeah no like um
World of Warcraft and stuff like that
where you can build your character and
all that [ __ ] yeah I played this game
called Star Wars Galaxies and there was
two people getting married in it and I
uh oh wow yeah I went to the wedding
with my brother and we role played that
he was sitting in my spot and I asked
him to please move and he refused and
back then in the game if you if you had
a certain weapon that you weren't
qualified to use you just missed the
whole time but it would still have the
effects of the weapon so I I then pulled
out like a blaster and I started rolling
and [ __ ] firing at him and the aisle
while the bride and groom were walking
and then he's finding a rocket launcher
at me and like missing because you miss
every time so we were doing that for
like [ __ ] an hour and during laughing
yeah yeah yeah you ruined her ruined
their wedding and it was like a huge
post on like the Sony Online
Entertainment forums about how like we
were Griefers and all the [ __ ] oh no and
they had to cancel the wedding yeah can
you imagine you ruined the digital only
people can do in the metaverse dude it's
I'm that's what I'm saying it's gonna be
ruined a real wedding I ruined a Star
Wars wedding in I don't know if there
were actually two people trying to get
married in real life but in the game but
but they took that [ __ ] dead seriously
they're dead serious bro they're walking
down the aisle and everything and
everybody's role playing and they asked
everybody to role play so I role played
like a little bar fight with my brother
and then yeah yeah we ruined it and we
were even like rolling like up next to
the private room like
like the whole thing in the way yeah
could you hear audio of people like
groaning and like saying no you can't
you couldn't hear the other people's
voices you could just hear all the
ambient explosion sounds the whole time
the blast was like
I'm surprised nobody else joined you
guys they didn't they were all taking it
very seriously no one shot you guys to
you
you agreed to duel each other so you
couldn't you can't just fight anybody
you want in the game it's a gentleman's
agreement yeah there's a there's a
beautiful little exploit that I already
uh found and yeah it was really fun
Imagine sitting in a digital wedding
like that dude you know dude they were
all lined up like I'm not getting like
lined up in a row and then the bride and
grew like walking out and [ __ ] and me
and him [ __ ] rolling and [ __ ] each
other throwing grenades and [ __ ] God I
wish you could hear what they were
saying that would have been well they
were typing stuff to us very mean thing
is that gonna be you in the metaverse oh
[ __ ] yeah dude that's me in every game
dude I'm the biggest [ __ ] talking stupid
[ __ ] that ever lived yeah The Game of
Life as well yeah it's me and Pirate
game do I set fire to my own boat
laughs